The final advantage of fragments,
doesn't involve user interfaces at all.
As you know, as visual components,
activities are destroyed and recreated,
whenever the device
configuration changes.
Most notably when the
screen orientation switches.
That makes sense,
because there's a good chance
we'll want to create a different layout,
to better suit the new configuration.
But, if we can use fragments
to break up visual activity modules,
why not logical ones as well?
It turns out we can do exactly that.
And because these
fragments are non-visual,
there's no need to recreate them
every time the UI needs updating.
Within the onCreatehandler
of your non-UI fragment,
call setRetainInstance,
passing in true, and return null,
within your onCreate view handler.
Then, once the parent activity is created,
you can kick off any connections,
threads or tasks that are bound
to the lifetime of the activity,
which don't need to be interrupted
every time the device rotates.